if you think about it
human intelligence has created all of
modern civilization
in a way that shows the power of
intelligence and how broad it can be
used
[Music]
our mission is solving intelligence to
advance science and benefit humanity
real research means doing the unknown
we try to create this unique environment
that is geared completely towards using
artificial intelligence for fast-paced
innovation all right everyone welcome to
deepmind we are embarking on what will
turn out to be the greatest adventure in
human scientific history
when we started deepmind we looked at
machine learning and neuroscience and
there was a good chance that this was
going to open up the possibility for
full artificial general intelligence our
goal is to have an algorithm that can do
everything end-to-end by itself we're
going to be pushing the balance in ways
that we don't even know as we're doing
the research and the development of agi
we need a system which can do any
cognitive tasks that a person can do and
it can scale potentially far beyond that
we're bridging that gap between
simulation and reality you want to find
a thing that's dramatically different to
anything you've ever seen before the
types of accomplishments we've had are
what most companies would dream of over
a company life cycle we've got five more
offices so we are truly international
now people think what's going on edema
there's some kind of magic going on i
really feel like this is willy wonka's
chocolate factory
the thesis was to use games and
simulations as a perfect proving ground
for developing ai we started working on
agents that are learning to play atari
games and they actually learn more
complex behaviors really quickly we're
going up the games ladder and actually
tackling more complex challenges deep
mind put its computer program to the
test against one of the brightest minds
in the world and won
[Applause]
all these stories just playing so smart
and that is that the real purpose of
working on games for us was always one
step on the way to making more general
systems there's so much we don't know
but how do we start thinking about the
downstream impact of our research how do
we pioneer responsibly as an
organization we take that job extremely
seriously by doing rigorous research in
ethics we actually have an opportunity
to rethink and say what could ai do for
society in a positive way
these are metrics from the renewables
project the more people who are using
these algorithms in ai the greater the
impact we're going to have on trying to
stop climate change we've already used
them in many domains for example
controlling plasma infusion reactors and
accurately predicting weather patterns
it's 48 degrees and clear in london or
generating realistic sounding voice for
google assistant with our wavenet system
hi how are you with the research that we
do the exploration aspect is very
important because we are attacking some
of the hardest problems in the world our
biggest scientific breakthrough today
has been protein folding with alpha fog
we used ai to solve a 50 year old grand
challenge in biology which then enabled
us to release the structure of all human
proteins
the implications are immense from better
understanding how diseases progress how
you can discover new drugs it's endless
the best inventions in the future are
going to come from disciplines being
combined so what that requires then is
more renaissance-like thinking to build
artificial intelligence we need creative
thinkers that can come up with something
that nobody has thought of yet i think
if you ask davinci you know he wouldn't
recognize the difference between art and
science and there's a real joy in that i
think
and if we can find those moments of
inspiration and apply them to problems
that are important to humankind that
would be a transformative moment for
society i just think this is the most
important piece of information that we
don't have great experiments tell you
something important whether they work or
whether they don't work the more you
fail the more you're going to learn i
encourage people to fail as fast as
possible
if it's systematically wrong you might
be learning that systematically wrong
physics the work here is hard but it
will all be worth it if we manage to
make a positive impact if we do achieve
this this has incredible medical
relevance everything we do here is a
celebration of the mind and knowledge
we're not trying to build a brain we're
just trying to take inspiration from the
brain where we can get it what is
consciousness what is dreaming for what
is creativity those kinds of questions i
think we're going to be able to try and
answer if we've learned one thing it's
that we're very bad judges of the
impossible
our mission is to understand as much of
the world as we can if we solve
intelligence ai i think it's the most
fantastic possible tool you could have
to help with that mission we want to do
the next big thing and that means trying
something that a lot of people think is
too hard and we're just gonna have a go
at it
[Music]
you